quelle est l'importance on va voir la
photo du tout noir de cette de ce
travail de cette découverte de cet
assemblage
bonsoir c'est absolument incroyable et
puis on plonge encore dans la voie
lactée et moi je peux vous dire une
chose j'adore mon métier pour ça là
c'est pour pouvoir faire ses sauts
temporels ce ce voyage ce tourisme de
l'espace où à la différence du tourisme
spatial qu'on effectue parce qu'on peut
aller n'importe où avec ces images là
c'est incroyable cette image là les
exceptionnels dans le sens où notre
notre trou noir de la voie lactée il est
très petit beaucoup plus petit que celui
qu'on a pris en photo en 2019 qui était
dans une galaxie pourtant très lointaine
mais qui était vraiment très massif qui
faisait mille fois plus de masse que
celui que l'on a actuellement là et il
faut se rendre compte que ce que l'on
voit là c'est vraiment une image du trou
noir le trou noir est au centre et on
voit la matière tourner très vite autour
de ce trou noir là qui émet de la
lumière parce qu'elle tourne très vite
c'est impressionnant dans l'anneau que
l'on voit ici oui il fait à peu près
leur [ __ ] de la planète
mercure qui tourne autour du soleil donc
on parle d'environ un diamètre de 140
millions de kilomètres et de la matière
se déplace au tour très très vite devant
qu'est ce qui à l'intérieur est ce que
ce match là je vous posais des questions
naïves enfantine mais qu'est ce qu'il ya
et c'est pas un trou c'est la masse est
tellement compacte que ça que ça elle
par gravité ça absorbe tout exactement
c'est une déformation de l'espace temps
en fait le terme technique d'un d'un
trou noir puis une déformation à
l'infini c'est à dire que toute la
matière qui rentrent n'arrive pas à s'en
échapper et cette matière là en fait est
transformée en énergie c'est une grosse
boule d'énergie grosse boule de masse et
à ceux à civaux là en fait en fait oui
il ya une masse mais la masse est aussi
de l'énergie c'est ça toute la beauté en
fait de la relativité générale et
d'einstein et de monsieur einstein le
fameux e égal mc2 qu'on a appris comme
ça sur les bancs d'école il prend toute
sa valeur ici parce qu'on est vraiment à
la limite
où il ya cette conversion entre la masse
et l'énergie et c'est ce que l'on a
devant les yeux c'est une une
illustration parfaite en fait de la
théorie de la relativité générale et
qu'est-ce que einstein a inventé il ya
plus de 100 ans mais je vous repose la
question ça nous donne quoi en quoi ça
nous avons scientifiquement
alors ça vérifie scientifiquement la
théorie de la relativité générale ça
c'est sûr
pourquoi parce que en fait pour pouvoir
obtenir cette image là on a dû faire des
simulations essayer de comprendre
comment se comporteraient et comment
évoluerez d'un trou noir qu'elle quelle
forme il aurait et les différentes
formes que l'on a eus montre se compare
très très bien à l'image qu'on a obtenu
donc c'est une confirmation nette et
précise de la théorie de la grappe de la
relativité générale d'einstein et ça va
nous amener plus loin ça va nous amener
à comprendre l'évolution de notre
galaxie à sa voix on a encore beaucoup
de mystères pourquoi en fait on a un
trou noir central au centre de notre
galaxie qu'est ce qu'il fait là comment
il est apparu est ce qu'il est apparu en
même temps que notre galaxie au moment
de sa formation ou est-ce qu'il est à
l'eau ce sont des phénomènes
cataclysmique qui sont à son origine un
peu plus tard dans la formation de de la
galaxie et surtout combien de temps il
va rester là on sait dans la théorie qui
va rester là pour un bon bout de temps
vraiment beaucoup plus que l'âge de
l'univers mais combien comment il va
évoluer on va maintenant pouvoir le
suivre et il ya des campagnes maintenant
d'observation justement dans les
prochaines années en 2022 et en 2024 com
comment va évoluer ce trou noir la
quelle va être sa forme plus tard n'en
fait pas beaucoup de choses qui vont
sortir de ça il est à 27 mille années
lumière de la terre oui tous pas comment
on a fait pour recréer c'est comment on
a fait n'est ce pas de photos où l'on
peut prendre comme en affaires alors on
utilise en fait une technique qui
s'appelle l'interférométrie est ce que
l'on fait c'est qu'on fait croire que on
utilise 8 télescope et ils sont un peu
éparpillée partout sur l'ensemble de du
disque de notre planète et on fait
croire en fait simplement à la lumière
qui arrive sur la planète terre que l'on
a un gros radiotélescope du diamètre de
la terre ce qui fait que ses
performances sa résolution est la
meilleure jamais obtenue et on est
capable de voir des fins détails même
s'ils sont situés très très loin la
résolution que l'on obtient c'est celle
de la en fait on serait capable de voir
avec son télescope là une balle de
tennis ou un donut si vous voulez un
beigne sur la surface de la lune
tellement la résolution et précise ou
alors encore une pièce de 25 cents situé
à vancouver on pourrait observer depuis
montréal d'affaires à sunderland huile
ça nous a salué sa et de l'anxiété de de
parler de l'immense et marc angrand mais
sur un death on voit ça mais on ne voit
toujours pas de charge le sujet vous
allez me dire mais avec nos instruments
les nouveaux
partis ou était ce qui est parti on ne
voit toujours pas dans cette voie lactée
je répète ya deux cent mille deux cent
mille 200 milliards de soleils jeu on ne
voit toujours pas sur des planètes
gravitant autour de ces 200 milliards de
soleils dans notre galaxie je parle pas
des eaux de joie de vie et non et c'est
ce qu'on cherche très fortement et
notamment avec le groupe de l'institut
de recherche sur les exoplanètes à
l'université de montréal l'objectif
c'est justement de trouver des traces de
vie des bio signature dans les
exoplanètes que vont observer des
télescopes comme le télescope spatial
james webb qui a été lancé au mois de
décembre l'objectif c'est d'aller
chercher en fait cette trace de vie mais
c'est extrêmement complexe en fait parce
que pour pouvoir trouver ça il faut
analyser les atmosphères des exoplanètes
et pour pouvoir analyser les atmosphères
des exoplanètes il suffit c'est très
facile à dire mais il suffit d'attendre
qu'une exoplanète passe devant son
étoile et de regarder la lumière avant
qu'elle soit passée et après qu'elle
soit passée puis de faire la différence
mais la lumière en fait on regarde
vraiment dé toute petite partie de la
lumière c'est très très faible comme
signal et il faut toute une équipe de
spécialistes qui est capable d'analyser
tout ça puis 2 2 voir ces bio signature
là et le télescope spatial james webb va
nous aider à dans cette conquête là et
les futurs grands télescopes on est en
train de développer sur la planète terre
des télescopes de 30 mètres vont nous
aider aussi à analyser un peu plus donc
il va falloir être patient un petit peu
pour pouvoir trouver des signes de vie
sur des exoplanètes peut-être qu'on aura
plus de chance d'abord de la trouver
dans notre système solaire parce que
c'est ce qu'on cherche par exemple avec
des missions comme persévérance sur mars
ou alors les futures missions sur les
lunes de saturne et de jupiter où il
annote système solaire ça serait très
bien mais dans la voie lactée dans notre
galaxie on se dit oui les probabilités
qu'elles sont là sont là la spa en car
oui c'est à l'évidence évident pour moi
c'est une évidence que sur 200 milliards
d'étoilés on peut avoir à peu près 2 3
planètes en moyenne par étoiles donc
qu'on fait le contient à peu près 600
milliards de possibilités de vie à
travers notre notre propre galaxie très
donc il est évident que quelques quelque
part il ya de la vie sur notre planète
mais je surnomme dans notre galaxie il
faut juste la trouver et c'est chercher
une aiguille dans une botte de foin
c'est ça qui est difficile fernandes qui
a dit qu'il y avait plus de il ya
davantage de soleil des toiles dans
notre voie lactée que de grains de sable
sur la terre c'est ce qu'avance est bon
c'est carl sagan qui a dit ça oui dans
son livre contact et il a tout à fait
raison fait donc les possibilités sont
très très grande avant de découvrir la
vie ailleurs dans notre dans notre
galaxie très bien à liverdun des acteurs
du planétarium rio tinto alcan on
voulait souligner c'était exploit
scientifique qui a été soulignée partout
sur la planète aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci beaucoup